contiamo subito il ghiaccio e diciamoci
la verità tutti noi ogni giorno dobbiamo
smontare qualche pregiudizio e allora
facciamo un test di sincerità alzino la
mano per favore tutti quelli che ieri
sera
volendo scoprire qualcosa di più su gli
speaker di oggi non appena iniziata
legge il mio profilo ha detto ma perché
mai
domani dovrei andare ad ascoltare un
notaio un sacco di bugiardi perché
andiamo avanti
e allora vi presento la mia famiglia mia
moglie flow che qui in prima fila le mie
bambine carla e viola
carla 11 anni e viola ne ha otto perché
vi presento la mia famiglia perché
quello che vi sto per raccontare non è
un progetto solomeo è un progetto di
un'intera famiglia avevo un progetto di
un'intera vita
io non sono un filosofo non sono un
organista non faccio politica sono un
cittadino normale esattamente come tutti
voi non ho i super poteri non sono
milionario e quello che sto facendo
insieme a mia moglie flop ea una
comunità di fondatori sognatori come noi
e cercare di fare il nostro meglio per
migliorare il luogo nel quale abbiamo
deciso di vivere ma facciamo un passo
indietro
siamo a boulevard dell'hopital siamo a
due passi dal jardine the plant e
dall'istituto di mondo arabo
siamo a parigi e il 2006 ed è lì che
decidiamo il 5 gennaio del 2006 di
affittare una piccola casa a parigi
mia figlia carla è appena nata da 20
giorni e abbiamo il desiderio con flo di
vivere questo momento così importante
per la nostra famiglia tutti e tre
insieme parigi è bellissima e il tempo
ovviamente scorre veloce caraffe per
compiere tre anni e dobbiamo decidere
dove vivere il nostro progetto di vita
a me sinceramente sembrava che parigi
fosse appena appena più sexy di favara
ma mia moglie mia moglie non ne vorrà
sentire di vivere rincorrendo c no io
non avrei potuto fare il notaio a parigi
e quindi avremmo dovuto fare avanti e
indietro
insomma sapete come funziona in questi
casi quando marito e moglie non sono
d'accordo decidemmo di ritornare a
favara decidemmo di ritornare a favara
ma facendoci una promessa non ci saremmo
lamentati per quello che non c'era o per
quello che non ci piaceva non avremmo
aspettato che il capo del governo il
presidente della regione o il sindaco di
favara ci cambiasse la vita
avremmo fatto tutto quello che era nelle
nostre possibilità per migliorare il
nostro quotidiano per dare a carlea
viola ea tutti i bambini favara un luogo
migliore in cui crescere e soprattutto
per trovare il nostro posto all'interno
della comunità nella quale avevamo
deciso di vivere
io oggi vi racconto questa storia che si
ambiente questo luogo e si chiama nei
sette cortili e invece di comprare una
villa a al mare o di comprare le tue
stanze a parigi dove andare una volta
l'anno
abbiamo deciso di comprare questi
piccoli e ruderi nel centro storico di
favara questo luogo si chiama sette
cortili e una piccola casbah siciliana e
qui convivono le zie i nativi dei sette
cortili noi di farm cultural park e
altri amici che poco alla volta e si
sono avvicinati a questo luogo è oggi vi
porto i saluti della zia maria la zia
maria più di 80 anni
qualcuno ha detto che questi sette
cortili sono un piccolo regno
e allora abbiamo deciso che la zia maria
e la regina dei sette cortili
io sono diventato il capo del governo
nei sette cortili e vito questo ragazzo
super muscoloso con qualche problema di
giustizia alle spalle e il capo delle
forze armate
ma cos'è farm cultural park
fare un punto al parquet un centro
culturale indipendente
qui l'arte la cultura diventano uno
strumento per cambiare l'identità di una
città e per dare una dimensione di
futuro è un luogo semplice e accogliente
è un luogo dove è piacevole stare ed è
piacevole ritornare perché un loro e
cambia sempre è un posto dove incontri
sempre qualcuno di speciale
qualche volta anche qualcuno un po
troppo speciale ma è farmaco se farne
anche il luogo della conoscenza e
dell'educazione
il nostro progetto più importante sono i
bambini sola scuola di architettura per
bambini pensate che durante l'anno
scorso i nostri bambini hanno incontrato
più di 50 docenti architetti designer
filosofi provenienti da tutte le parti
d'italia hanno incontrato pure due
curatori e la biennale di venezia con
loro progettano grattacieli per gatti
qui c'è francesco gatti hanno fatto lui
e progettano monumenti progettano
giardini orti sociali progettano lugli
per bambini per adulti persino per
marziani e la settimana scorsa siamo
stati a roma torpignattara e abbiamo
avuto il privilegio di lavorare con 40
bambini di 24 nazionalità differenti e
pensate la scuola che è nata a ferrara
un anno fra un anno fa con poltrona frau
grazie al sostegno di poltrona frau sta
girando il mondo
siamo stati a londra e abbiamo
collaborato con dejan su dice il
direttore del design museum di londra
tra due settimane saremo a shanghai
e poi ancora a parigi dove incontreremo
il suo fujimoto al quale abbiamo
dedicato il nome della scuola di
architettura e poi ancora a milano a new
york e vi devo dire con molto orgoglio
che quello che stanno facendo i nostri
bambini a favara i bambini di londra new
york e anche di parigi possono solo
sognare di farlo ma farne anche luogo in
cui ci prendiamo cura degli adolescenti
abbiamo un festival che si chiama op
quest'anno la seconda edizione ho
progettato con gli adolescenti ci
prendiamo cura dei giovani del talento
ci prendiamo cura degli artisti ci
prendiamo cura anche delle persone che
ospitiamo nel nostro paese perché farm
non è un museo tradizionale far non ha
una collezione d'arte contemporanea
da noi le opere sono spesso immateriale
intangibili il più delle volte effimere
quello che conta realmente da noi e il
valore delle persone che passano per
questo ogni tanto utilizziamo
l'espressione museo delle persone
tutto questo è generato un'onda di
entusiasmo incredibile una voglia di
riscatto
un desiderio di essere attori di un
cambiamento che ha portato tanti giovani
imprenditori professionisti a dare il
loro massimo per cambiare questa città
sentite cosa dicono loro di quello che
sta accadendo
a favara sta succedendo ciò che dovrebbe
succedere in ogni parte
un forte senso di solidarietà c'è una
sana competizione una sana voglia
cresce nella propria città favara non è
più paese da cui si scappa da cui si va
via da cui si piglia come bagagli e si
emigra che c'erano l'energia una forte
energia giovani e sembra di stare in un
posto come berlino 20 aspettersti mai
ritrovare in mezzo
ci ha dato a tutti la forza di come dire
guardare dentro
di creare comunità di far sì che ognuno
di noi potesse dare il meglio di sé al
cambiamento più significativo nella
fiducia
dei cittadini nella fiducia di cambiare
le cose c'è la consapevolezza e la forza
di dire è possibile cambiare
attraverso i servizi di igiene nella
volontà che vede in se stessi ma come
comunità con i cittadini
c'è qualcuno che toccava per schede
delle pagine di storia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
favara in passato quando andava bene era
la città dell'agnello pasquale il più
delle volte nella città della mafia dei
latitanti dell'abusivismo oggi favore
diventata la città dei giovani della
sperimentazione della creatività favore
è diventata una piccola capitale della
rigenerazione urbana è pensato in un
luogo in cui non arrivava un turista
neanche per sbaglio
oggi da più di tre anni e registriamo
più di 100.000 presenze ogni è stata io
credo che ognuno di noi ha la sensazione
le grandi città del mondo le città più
belle del mondo siano nate tali così
come le percepiamo facciamo fatica in
realtà pensare che persone esattamente
come noi con due gambe e due braccia una
bella testa ne hanno fatti diventare
quelle che oggi sono queste città
e allora credo fortemente che le città
candino perché le persone ne fanno
cambiare
detta così sembra una passeggiata di
salute in realtà stiamo lavorando un
progetto molto più grande di noi questa
estate pensate abbiamo dovuto anche
sventare un attacco della burocrazia
locale ordine di demolizione rimessa in
pristino di cinque installazioni di
architetti contemporanei la dovevamo
fatto una richiesta regolare di
autorizzazione aveva pagato il solo
pubblico per fortuna è bastata una
semplice del truck su facebook per
sollevare un muro a nostra protezione
tutti i media nazionali ne hanno parlato
e persino la procura della repubblica
il 15 di agosto per ferragosto ha
ordinato agli stessi vigili che aveva
messo questi giri di andare a rimuoverli
e di liberare la farma e allora capite
che le cose si possono fare e che
dipende da noi dobbiamo semplicemente
noi che siamo un po più fortunati
provare a restituire qualcosa indietro
io sono certo che in questa sala tra
queste 900 persone sanno tantissimi di
voi che hanno avuto una volta il
desiderio di
qualcosa di speciale eppure ci sarà
stato qualcuno che accanto a voi un
familiare un parente un amico mi ha
detto no questa cosa non la puoi fare è
impossibile non ce la puoi fare
sapete cosa vi dico si sbagliano
e allora vi voglio lasciare con un
desiderio quello vecchio
il mio desiderio è questa sera ognuno di
voi possa chiedersi cosa potrebbe fare
per rendervi felici e orgogliosi di voi
stessi pensando a cosa potreste fare per
voi e per chi vi sta vicino per i vostri
figli e per le future generazioni per la
vostra città e per il nostro paese e
soprattutto che domani mattina domenica
12 novembre 2017
iniziate a farlo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]